et c'est le retour d'un club historique
ce matin bonjour Nathalie Moret merci
avec nous journaliste politique pour les
journaux régionaux du groupe Evra les
journaux de l'Est de la France et Yves
réars bonjour tendre vers Nathalie avec
nous
directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
Figaro alex est revenue évidemment on
parlera des états généraux de la droite
les républicains se sont réunis samedi
pour lancer leur reconstruction ils
veulent affirmer une ligne ferme une
droite forte et conquérante mais
peuvent-ils rester autonome peuvent-ils
se passer d'une alliance avec Emmanuel
Macron vous nous direz ce que vous en
pensez et puis à la fin de ce club a un
an des Jeux olympiques de Paris on vous
emmènera voir la rencontre entre des
sénateurs et des athlètes vendredi des
démonstrations de disciplines peu
connues avaient lieu dans les jardins du
Luxembourg à Paris vous verrez le
reportage dans une demi-heure d'abord on
regarde l'actualité dans nos régions
et l'actualité dans nos régions avec nos
partenaires de la presse régionale et on
va parler du lion Turin qui a suscité
suscité de nombreuses mobilisations ce
week-end pour en parler on retrouve
Frédéric Thiers bonjour Frédéric merci
d'être avec nous chef d'agence du
Dauphiné Libéré à
Saint-Jean-de-Maurienne et on va revenir
avec vous évidemment Frédéric sur cette
manifestation non déclaré interdite qui
a eu lieu ce week-end pour s'opposer au
tunnel Lyon Turin 3000 manifestants
selon la police
[Musique]
ça peut paraître bien léger au regard
des dégâts qui on peut trouver dans une
émeute à Paris par exemple mais je vous
assure qu'à l'échelle d'une vallée de
45000 habitants ça marque nous les
habitants les manifestants pardon ne
sont pas fait que des amis sur le coup
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
en revanche il n'y a pas pour l'heure de
création de ZAD en Maurienne c'est un
peu ce qui était craint il est vrai que
contrairement à Notre-Dame-des-Landes le
lion Turin c'est un chantier déjà
largement entamé et il n'y a plus guère
de sites à occuper pour empêcher la mise
en chantier
de la terre se sont offert une tribune
nationale le dossier du lion Turin
jusque là il était très largement resté
un débat local et aujourd'hui il a pris
une résonance bien plus large tout le
monde en entend parler la française
soumise et Europe Écologie Les Verts
sont saisir on se demande bien pourquoi
parce qu'a priori il y a pas plus
écologique de mettre des camions sur les
trains et les arguments sur la capacité
de la ligne actuelle à accepter de
nouveaux trafic ne tiennent vraiment pas
la route pardonner le mot sur le plan
technique
quoi qu'il en soit le lion Turin c'est
le nouveau cheval de bataille d'une
certaine gauche certainement pas de
toute la gauche puisque comme une liste
et socialiste reste d'ardent partisans
du lion Turin comme la droite et le
centre d'ailleurs quand on rassemble
national il se tait sur le sujet on ne
l'entend pas tout à sa stratégie de
lissage de l'image
maintenant c'est un dossier de temps
long on parle du tunnel de base on vient
d'avoir des images mais les accès
français sur lesquels on attend toujours
la vraie décision du gouvernement ne
seront pas mis en chantier en 2030 pour
l'instant on s'occupe surtout de ne pas
laisser la déclaration d'utilité
publique de venir caduque si rien n'est
fait avant 2028 là il y a un risque
clairement de type zadistes bien sûr si
la galaxie rouge vert n'est pas d'ici là
avec les échelles en sélectoral qui
s'approche passer à autre chose
merci merci Frédéric d'avoir été avec
nous pour nous parler de ce qui s'est
passé ce week-end du côté des Alpes il
s'est manifestations contre le projet
Lyon-Turin regarde la ligne du Dauphiné
Libéré aujourd'hui le coût d'arrêt pour
les constructions tout autre sujet si on
pourra avoir l'impression que c'est le
même sujet mais c'est un autre sujet
merci beaucoup Frédéric d'avoir été avec
nous un mot Yves sur ce dossier du lion
Turin il s'est manifestations qui ont
lieu ce week-end et Frédéric le
rappelait c'est un projet qui date
depuis des années et qui ont dont on
parle depuis le début des années 90 qui
est bien lancé du côté italien qui est
au point mort du côté français oui c'est
un serpent de mer comme on dit bien sûr
c'est le papier ce qui vient d'être dit
a été excellent Mendi et je crois qu'il
y a pas beaucoup de choses à ajouter
c'est vrai qu'on comprend pas pourquoi
les il y a une opposition aussi musclée
à cette à ces initiative à ce chantier
mais quand on fait de la politique on
mieux c'est à dire qu'ils ont une il
faut qu'ils existent maintenant c'est ce
qu'on appelle que j'appelle pas trop les
CA terrorisme moi parce que c'est
terroriste c'est quand même très
particulier mais c'est de l'écho
délinquance ça revient à ça et bah ils
ont encore fait aujourd'hui ils ont
encore fait parler d'eux pendant le
weekend
j'aimerais qui est un rapport qui soit
un rapport que je ne connais pas moi
fiable entre le nouveau tunnel et
l'ancien tunnel c'est ça qui
m'intéresserait de connaître est-ce que
l'ancien tunnel qui n'est pas exploitée
à sa totale capacité et bien faire voilà
c'était ça le c'était ça le c'est ça à
mon avis la grande question Nathalie moi
je trouve que ce qui est le plus
important en tous les cas moi ce qui m'a
plus
perturbé enfin qui a touché ce weekend
devant c'est ça c'est ce qu'a dit mon
collègue c'est le fait que les
soulèvements de la terre ont mis ce
problème sur le au niveau national moi
effectivement travaillons au groupe et
bras donc notamment au Progrès de Lyon
et au Dauphiné Libéré c'est un sujet
j'ai le sentiment qui est traité au fil
de l'eau depuis 15 20 ans même et
effectivement là ça devient
une problématique nationale donc je
pense que c'est vraiment le le sujet
important et on le doit au soulèvement
de la terre et le soulèvement de la
terre il va y avoir un gros sujet cette
semaine puisque sa possible probable
dissolution va être discuté ce mercredi
en Conseil des ministres et je vous
parie que par exemple demain aux
questions au gouvernement à l'Assemblée
nationale ou mercredi aux questions
gouvernement au Sénat ça va être un
sujet absolument majeur pourquoi on fait
qu'est-ce qui fait que aujourd'hui on
dit sous ce mouvement est-ce que quelle
est la différence entre
l'écotéroïsme ou simplement les lanceurs
d'alerte c'est tout le sujet du
soulèvement de la terre et je trouve que
c'est le sujet intéressant que nous
apprend
quand on les a vu à l'oeuvre notamment à
et ici ou là en France c'est tout à fait
intolérable quoi une attitude qui est
tout à fait détestable et qui à mon avis
mérite dissolution si c'est le cas je
sais pas si c'est d'ailleurs ça sera
très efficace mais ils ont une attitude
qui est absolument détestable alors
effectivement vous avez raison il y a
des comportements qu'ils sont
répréhensibles qui tombent sous le coup
de la loi et donc ils doivent être voilà
juger mais il y a deux différences il y
a des comportements délinquants qui
doivent être jugés par des voilà ok mais
est-ce que ça vaut dissolution c'est à
dire que est-ce que la dissolution d'un
mouvement aussi important qui croisent
des problématiques environnementales qui
sont portées par un maximum de jeunes
beaucoup beaucoup de jeunes encore une
fois ça ne ça n'enlève rien au fait qui
est parfois des comportements délictueux
mais est-ce que dissoudre un tel
mouvement qui croise la volonté de
autant de personnes dans la société en
mouvement fort dans la société est-ce
que ça va être quelque chose qui peut
pas avoir un effet boomerang moi c'est
la question que je me
effectivement cette association les
soulèvements de la terre elle divise la
classe politique et une partie de la
gauche qui les soutient la droite est
vent debout contre cette association et
d'ailleurs et bien l'annonce du
gouvernement de la proposition de
dissolution qui doit être faite mercredi
en Conseil des ministres et bien on l'a
appris mercredi dernier à la séance de
questions d'actualité au Gouvernement du
Sénat à une réponse à une question d'une
sénatrice les républicains de
Loire-Atlantique c'est justement
revenaient sur une dernière action des
soulèvements de la terre qui est bien
avait arraché des cultures maraîchères
en Loire-Atlantique des cultures
maraîchères qui notamment servaient à
une expérimentation en vue du
réchauffement climatique pour avoir des
salades plus résistantes donc parfois et
bien l'action de ces militants
écologistes est un petit peu
contre-productif vis-à-vis de l'écologie
samedi avait lieu les états généraux de
la droite les républicains qui se sont
réunis à Paris pour entamer leur
reconstruction ils veulent incarner une
ligne droite une ligne forte c'est ce
que dit leur président mais peuvent-ils
rester indépendants les réponses
diverses je voudrais Audrey Vittaz et
Hugo Lemonnier se sont rendus au Cirque
d'Hiver les républicains le savent
ils ont récemment imposé un rapport de
force avec le gouvernement sur
l'immigration c'est sur cette base que
les ténors de droite à l'exception de
Laurent Wauquiez ont lancé six mois
d'états généraux en grande pompe devant
un millier de militants l'objectif c'est
de trouver d'autres thèmes forts et des
lignes claires sur l'écologie l'école ou
encore le logement tout pour ne pas
rejouer la séquence des retraites et les
divisions qui ont perdu les électeurs
de certaines personnes qui allaient à
Langon de ce qui avait
été
mes problèmes cette volonté d'unité
pourrait rapidement voler en éclat au
moment où la majorité présidentielle
réfléchit à un accord de gouvernement
avec la droite pour tenter de capter les
40 voies qui lui manquent à l'Assemblée
d'un côté il y a ceux pour qui elle air
doit rester à tout prix dans
l'opposition comme Gérard Larcher qui
ferme la porte aux rumeurs je reste
convaincu
que la bonne stratégie doit être
l'indépendance et la responsabilité
cette majorité relative n'est pas la
nôtre nos différences sont très
profondes il est rejoint par Eric Ciotti
le président du parti la droite est là
la droite est debout la droite est
indépendante elle n'est soumise à aucune
influence elle n'est la supplétive de
personnes elle est forte elle veut
gagner et elle veut occuper la seule
place qui vaille c'est à dire la
première mais aussi ceux qui ont affiché
leur différence par le passé Xavier
Bertrand et Aurélien Pradier je pense
que plus clairement on le dira mieux ce
sera nous n'avons pas vocation à
magouiller avec Emmanuel Macron on peut
pas le matin dire qu'il a fait un mal
incroyable à ce pays et le soir espérer
en être son son marche-pied pourquoi je
suis un opposant par contre si on
pouvait réfléchir cette politique ce
serait vraiment bien ce serait bien pour
la France ce serait bien pour les
Français mais il y a aussi à droite des
voies qui prônent le pragmatisme sous
condition on peut pas continuer comme ça
moi je vais vous dire j'ai beaucoup de
peine de voir l'état de la France
regardez la réforme des retraites les
débats franchement on s'est quand même
tous déchirés ou entre déchirés donc on
peut trouver peut-être un terrain
d'entente qu'on est un accord politique
de gouvernement on est et puis parce que
on va pas faire 4 ans comme ça
le président de la République dit banco
je suis pas allé mettre en application
si vous acceptez un pack sur des projets
immigration sécurité éducation on peut
réfléchir mais si c'est juste pour faire
du débauchage non pour Bruno Retailleau
la droite aurait beaucoup trop à perdre
et je le dis aussi à mes amis qui
pourraient être intéressés par tel ou
telle place au gouvernement je pense que
attention on est une démocratie qui est
en crise qui est très fatiguée et je
pense que ce genre d'accord on doit le
faire en toute transparence lorsqu'il y
a une élection et certainement pas dans
les couloirs par des marchandages on
doit se refonder on doit sur chaque
sujet avoir des textes de loi prêt à
l'emploi c'est comme ça qu'on arrivera à
se recrédibiliser l'objectif est clair
tenter de revenir au pouvoir en 2027
Nathalie vous y étiez on va évidemment
parler longuement de la question de la
ligne et de l'indépendance mais d'abord
on a entendu quelques divisions est-ce
que les républicains peuvent retrouver
leur unité perdue sur la réforme des
retraites
non non parce qu'il y a eu effectivement
eu des divisions entre ils peuvent pas
la retrouver par contre ils peuvent
établir un socle
idéologique dans le l'objectif afin
d'enlever de 2027 et c'était l'objectif
de cette réunion on ferons construire
par le fond ben oui c'est ça alors en
même temps c'est pas la première fois
qu'ils essayent de le faire puisque je
vous rappelle que ils ont quand même
perdu toutes les élections depuis 2012
et à la dernière ils ont fait 4,78% au
premier tour donc c'est pas la première
fois et c'est là où je mets un petit un
petit peu un bémol parce que je me
rappelle qu'après la défaite de 2017
donc après la défaite de François Fillon
que beaucoup voyaient président avant
que il lui arrive ce qu'on sait donc en
2017 Bernard accueilli à l'époque avait
fait des sorts d'états généraux ça
s'applait pas comme ça mais bon il y
avait eu effectivement une tentative de
revenir au fond et d'établir une ligne
politique et ça c'était terminé au bout
de plusieurs mois discussions avec un
grand interview dans le Figaro de
Bernard à cahier qui disait ça y est la
droite est de retour et on a retrouvé la
boussole
6 ans après le thème c'était ou
maladroite donc la boussole il l'avait
retrouvé mais pas longtemps donc on voit
qu'à chaque fois il y a des tentatives
de renverser la table qui sont claires
là je veux dire vraiment il y a eu des
discussions de fond samedi il y a eu des
débats importants mais moi là où le
bémol que je mets c'est est-ce que ça va
à quoi vraiment ça va servir puisque
Eric Ciotti président des républicains à
parler pendant trois quarts d'heure il a
parlé de sécurité d'immigration il a eu
un discours extrêmement ferme sur les
bases d'une droite forte donc on a le
sentiment que la ligne elle est déjà là
et qu'elle a identique a été édictée par
erikiotti donc est-ce que tout ça est
pas un peu de l'affichage moi c'est un
petit peu la question que je me pose et
juste dernière chose dans la salle il y
avait effectivement des militants mais
il y avait quasiment pas de
parlementaires donc quand vous êtes là
pour parler du fond pour établir une
ligne pour essayer de retrouver ce qu'on
a en commun et qu'il y a trois sénateurs
et quatre députés ça pose un peu
question
effectivement ça intéresse est-ce que
les républicains ils peuvent se
reconstruire à travers un projet est-ce
que cette tentative elle peut aboutir
je sais pas si elle peut aboutir parce
qu'il manque sérieusement et
singulièrement d'incarnation il n'y a
pas une incarnation forte donc là c'est
ils
occupe un peu le terrain mais d'abord le
projet on verra l'incarnation après pour
vous ça peut pas dire
tous les partis politiques qui sont et
toutes les formations qui sont en
difficulté dites ça le malheur c'est que
c'est le contraire quand vous n'avez pas
d'incarnation forte vous n'existez pas
le Parti socialiste une fois qu'il y a
plus
d'incarnation il y a plus de parties
socialistes c'est pareil pour la droite
c'est pareil pour le rassemblement
national c'est pareil pour tous les
partis donc on arrête avec ces histoires
d'abord les idées et tout ça c'est je
dirais c'est des éléments de langage ça
l'intérêt c'est l'intérêt de la ce qui
est primordial c'est d'avoir une
incarnation forte du charisme du talent
et ça il y en a pas bon bah voilà ils en
sont là maintenant aujourd'hui ce qui
fait que les Français qu'est-ce qu'ils
voient ils regardent ils regardent ils
se disent que le gouvernement actuel
finalement c'est la droite s'il est là à
droite classique qu'on avait l'habitude
de voir
parfois un peu timoré quand il s'agit de
sujets régaliens et ben elle est au
gouvernement elle est à l'Élysée elle
est à Matignon mais ils ont ils disent
pas mieux là et qu'est-ce qu'ils disent
comment les croire la droite c'est ça un
peu le problème justement aussi qu'ils
ont ils peuvent faire tous les
tous les meetings toutes les conventions
qu'ils veulent ils ont perdu du crédit
parce que on parle d'immigration mais
quand il fait quand il était au
gouvernement terre pour vous ils sont
pas en position de force sur cette
séquence immigration il parle beaucoup
mais bon
est-ce que dit yves est très juste parce
que effectivement on a vu samedi Éric
Ciotti dire que l'ennemi c'était
l'extrême gauche et c'est à peu près
dans ces termes qu'il a dit et 10
minutes plus tard dans les couloirs
devant la caméra Rachida Dati disait bah
non l'ennemi c'est pas l'extrême gauche
c'est l'état de la France et il faut
qu'on se batte pour pour monter la
France etc donc on voit bien qu'il y
avait deux lignes il y avait celles qui
étaient déjà sur 2027 en disant voilà on
se projette déjà contre Mélenchon et
Rachida Dati et d'autres qui n'étaient
pas dans la salle pour le dire mais
d'autres qui disent bah non il y a quand
même des choses à travailler aujourd'hui
maintenant pour les Français et pourquoi
pas on est dans le gouvernement sur
certains points et en point et en étant
très clair par rapport à ça donc cette
ligne là pour ou anti Macron pro ou
contre Macron elle est toujours pas
tranchée et en tous les cas la réunion
de samedi a pas contribué à le faire et
vous qui étiez samedi Nathalie elle
représente alors il y a ceux qui sont
pour un accord Rachida Dati on l'a
entendu il y a ceux qui sont contre on
va y revenir le parti des divisé à peu
près comment
honnêtement non c'est assez facile à
dire c'est une immense majorité des gens
qui étaient là des gens qui sont encore
à LR sont contre Emmanuel Macron très
clairement il y a eu des images qui ont
été diffusées dans des clips etc et dès
qu'il était fait allusion ou qu'on
voyait Emmanuel Macron il y avait
immédiatement des sifflé donc on voit
bien que les gens qui restent
aujourd'hui aux républicains sont des
gens qui sont plus proches d'Eric
Zemmour que d'Emmanuel Macron très
clairement mais Rachida Dati par exemple
fait le pari que pour gagner en 2027 il
faudra rassembler à la fois sur sa
droite et sur le centre droit et elle
dit on peut pas continuer peut-être un
mot sur l'état de santé de ce parti on
dit il est très mauvais voilà c'est un
état un parti en mort cérébrale et quand
on regarde non non mais quand on dit
voilà ils ont eu beaucoup de défaites
électorales mais quand on regarde il y a
quand même certaines élections ou
notamment au niveau local ils sont très
présents la droite a eu un peu plus de
la moitié des communes ils ont des
conseils départementaux des conseils
régionaux voilà ils ont ils ont la
majorité au Sénat et le Sénat dans ce
donc quinquennat avec une majorité
relative à l'Assemblée à un poids
d'autant plus important que il peut
faire passer certains textes donc ils
ont quand même une force politique un
effectif d'élus qui est existe leur seul
problème c'est de réussir au niveau
national notamment présidentielle
européenne et au niveau national il y a
quand même même si bien sûr
l'incarnation se pose il y a quand même
un enjeu de ligne politique car c'est un
fait d'avoir une ligne politique qui
rassemble les militants notamment sur le
régalien sur la sécurité mais encore
faut-il et bien convaincre une majorité
de Français et c'est peut-être ça leur
défi alors pour aller dans votre sens
samedi il y a eu un comment dire un
sondage qui a été présenté au Cirque
d'Hiver là où se tenais les États
généraux le sondage était très clair
là-dessus la marque LR est une marque
qui existe qui est connue des Français
et qui n'est pas du tout démonétisée
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement une
majorité des Français de mémoire c'est
62% estime que le parti des républicains
a un avenir donc on voit bien que la
marque elle est forte elle existe
simplement ce que les son disait c'est
que même si elle existe il y a quand
même des des comment dire des des
inconvénients des des manques sur cette
marque sur deux points principalement
autant LR et reconnue sur par exemple
l'immigration sur les finances publiques
sur les choses comme ça mais pas du tout
sur le féminisme et sur l'environnement
et le féminisme et lance l'environnement
sont deux thèmes qui vont compter dans
les années à venir et les politologues
qui étaient présents disaient que
effectivement les LR devaient faire leur
joggiamento
sur ces thèmes là justement c'est
toujours la difficulté vous souvenez de
Nicolas Sarkozy qui avait dit au moment
juste après le PACS finalement on a eu
tort de s'opposer au PACS parce qu'on a
montré une image ringarde ok mais quand
ils sont dans le dans l'instant et dans
l'événement
franchir le pas c'est compliqué parce
qu'ils sont obligés de de ce
singulariser donc féminisme l'écologie
ou si l'écologie ils ont ils ont pas du
tout
le problème de LR c'est que enfin le
problème le je dirais le défi qui est
posé à LR effectivement moi je suis
d'accord c'est un parti qui compte c'est
un parti qui est encore une énergie
c'est évident mais
il a une place à jouer et un coup à
jouer pour 2027 qu'est-ce qui se passe
en 2027 bah justement celui qui pourrait
incarner la droite aujourd'hui qui
s'appelle Emmanuel Macron ne pourra pas
se représenter donc dans l'axe central
vous allez avoir
une place à occuper une place à
occuper qui sera entre le centre gauche
et le centre droit et grosso modo entre
Bernard Cazeneuve et et Bruno Retailleau
donc là vous allez avoir quoi 7 8 9 10
personnes qui vont vouloir postuler et
vous allez avoir
effectivement Bruno Le Maire vous allez
avoir
Darmanin vous allez avoir Philippe vous
allez avoir probablement peut-être
taillot peut-être d'autres et à gauche
vous aurez peut-être Cazeneuve vous
aurez peut-être des gars il a c'est
celui qui sera le meilleur de de
Laurent Wauquiez aussi c'est celui qui
sera meilleur pardon il peut encore
peser vous disiez tout à l'heure le
problème des républicains c'est qu'ils
ont pas de leader ça on n'est pas un
pour vous mais il faut encore qu'il le
prouve pour le moment il en est pas il
est président d'une région d'une très
grande région mais est-ce que il a quand
même été renvoyé à ses chers études à
l'issue de 2 ans de mandat à la tête des
républicains
à la fois des gens Bruno Le Maire Gérald
Darmanin qui sont rentrés dans le
gouvernement et Bruno retaille mais
est-ce que est-ce que grosso modo il
pense tous la même chose c'est il est là
le sujet c'est qu'en plus avec ces deux
c'est de radicalité qui se sont
installés à la droite et à gauche
central si vous voulez
paraît beaucoup plus large et
ou alors il faut qu'il nous le dise ou
alors il faut que
Eric Ciotti nous dise ben moi je préfère
le rassemblement national ou
une majorité de gouvernement il faut que
Bernard Cazeneuve dise je préfère la
vitesse
c'est à dire la ligne indépendante ou
c'est pas possible en fait les LR ils
font le pari que pour l'instant vous
l'avez dit il y a trois blocs il y a
l'extrême droite
deux extrêmes et puis un espace central
ils font le parti le pari pardon que on
va de passer le 3 blocs à deux blocs de
nouveau y avoir une droite et une gauche
sans espace central c'est ça leur pari
c'est aussi le pari d'une certaine forme
de enfin de certains à gauche pour
l'instant bien malin qui pourra dire si
effectivement cet espace central va être
occupé ou pas et tout ça dépendra
l'incarnation soit Édouard Philippe et
Bernard Cazeneuve pour faire simple
arrive à s'imposer et effectivement il y
a un espace central qui se crée soit il
y en a pas il y a ce moment-là on peut
effectivement assister à une
bipolarisation de la politique française
mais du coup parce que Nathalie elle
disait il y a un sondage vous me parliez
ce sondage qui a été présenté aux
républicain samedi et vous me disiez que
la républicains qui étaient présents
cercle d'hiver était majoritairement
contre une alliance avec les manuels
Macron il y a un sondage
dans le Figaro et je dis que les
français eux sont majoritairement pour
une alliance entre les républicains et
Emmanuel Macron 56% oui bien sûr ce qui
est pas énorme c'est quand même très
serré le match est serré
je pense que c'est à l'image de ce
qu'est le parti républicain aujourd'hui
entre la ligne Rachida Dati Nicolas
Sarkozy
Jean-François Copé d'un côté Roger
carochi et puis l'autre ligne retaille
Retailleau qui est un peu au centre il
s'est ni oui ni non d'une certaine façon
et puis une ligne qui est franchement
hostile à ça
qui est incarné principalement par Éric
fiotti d'ailleurs oui dans les discours
des cadres des républicains on a
l'impression que c'est ceux qui sont
contre une alliance avec Emmanuel Macron
ceux qui veulent discuter mais
effectivement effectivement Yves il y a
aussi une zone grise notamment au Sénat
où on pratique finalement une forme de
nouveau en même temps le en même temps
dans l'opposition et en même temps et
bien avec le gouvernement notamment sur
la réforme des retraites oui il y a
quand même une majorité LR assez forte
qui a soutenu ce texte donc c'est une
ligne de crête assez ténue notamment que
défend genre Larcher il a encore rappelé
dans ses états généraux de la droite à
la fois indépendant mais dans la
responsabilité c'est pas facile à tenir
mais est-ce que les républicains ils
sont en mesure d'infléchir sur la
politique du gouvernement
oui parce que clairement là la réforme
des retraites c'est derrière nous c'est
passé d'accord donc maintenant que ça a
été extrêmement dur les oppositions
elles font monter les enchères et c'est
ce que fait exactement le groupe les
républicains ils sont 62 alors c'est pas
énorme mais le gouvernement a besoin de
pour faire passer les textes donc comme
ça a été très tendu sur les retraites
les oppositions tout un les LR comme le
PS une partie de laupes disent bon bah
ok nous on veut bien vous aider pour
faire passer les textes mais maintenant
c'est plus cher donc voilà vous prenez
telle amendement etc on est dans la
tambouille parlementaire et c'est
exactement ce que fait de façon très
intelligente d'ailleurs le parti enfin
le parti des républicains en proposant
par exemple ces deux fameuses
propositions de loi ben ils mettent le
prix sur la table est-ce que on si
jamais il y a un accord avec les
républicains ce qu'Emmanuel Macron ne va
pas perdre au sein de sa majorité et
notamment le modem
de François
fait semblant mais il y aura pas
d’accord parce que le Président de la
République c'est très bien que il perdra
une partie de sa majorité il sera sans
doute en délicatesse avec le Modem
effectivement parce que Bayrou est quand
même un une personnalité de la majorité
qui compte donc on va rester dans ce
statut là et puis on va avancer au cas
par cas il y aura pas de pacte je pense
pas qu'il y a de pacte il y aura sans
doute pas de gros textes non plus parce
que là on a passé les retraites il va y
avoir les migration mais après
[Musique]
et peut-être et après quel gros texte
passera je suis pas persuadé qu'il y
aura des textes absolument très très
importants etc ce qui pose d'ailleurs le
problème du second quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron qu'est-ce qui va
laisser comme trace le tournant pour les
euros pour les républicains pardon ça va
être la campagne des européennes c'est
pas un tournant parce que les
européennes sur le
sur pour les républicains bon moi c'est
une une élection qui va montrer
qui sont oui alors effectivement ils se
sont la première je dirais signal
d'alarme ça a été la dernière européenne
où il pensait à un moment flirté à
12-14% finalement ils sont retrouvés à
7% on verra ça dépendra aussi de la
des candidats qu'ils présentent s'ils
ont une incarnation forte pour le moment
il y a des rumeurs qui courent comme
quoi ça serait Michel Barnier suivi par
François-Xavier Bellamy
on verra c'est le tandem qui qui tient
la corde en tout cas avec Michel Barnier
qui prendrait la place de François et
voilà le but DLR et ça fait plusieurs
députés me l'ont dit dernièrement c'est
leur dernière score en 2019 c'était 8 48
il faut surtout pas faire moins donc si
ils font dans les tirages de 8 11 on va
voilà tout est possible pour la
présidentielle moins c'est compliqué
mais ils l'ont en ligne de mien cette
élection européenne où ils veulent le
plus possible la faire passer sous les
radars honnêtement lune de mire non non
c'est pas leur voilà c'est genre c'est
comment dire c'est une passe difficile
il va falloir passer mais plus vite ce
sera passé plus mieux ce sera c'est un
peu sale sentiment on suivra ça
évidemment avec vous on va parler de
Gérard Larcher mais dans un tout autre
contexte puisque vendredi dernier le
jardin du Luxembourg est devenu le
terrain de jeu de deux disciplines
olympiques plus connus dans le
breakdance qui fait son entrée aux JO
l'occasion pour les sénateurs et Gérard
Larcher de découvrir ses sports Adrien
point les a suivi
des sénateurs face à un match de basket
3 3 un type de basket qui se joue avec
deux équipes de 3 pour Gérard Larcher
c'est une totale découverte la règle des
trois proies pour un président du Sénat
qui pas grand chose
en dehors du sport
le président du Sénat écoute
attentivement les explications de Marie
FPG sacré championne du monde de basket
3 3 l'année dernière le jardin du
Luxembourg a aussi accueilli une
démonstration de breakdance dans le
public le sénateur Daniel brouiller fait
partie des rares a déjà bien connaître
les deux sports les trois trois c'est
une discipline extrêmement spectaculaire
j'adore cette discipline le breakdance
aussi on est dans un autre registre j'ai
une petite fille qui braque et donc je
viendrai également très très volontiers
aux JO de Paris assisté à ces à ces
épreuves parce que 3 3 a fait son entrée
aux JO à Tokyo en 2020 compte au
breakdance il sera une discipline
olympique pour la première fois en 2024
c'est formidable de mettre à l'honneur
c'est sport moderne urbain hypertonique
le JO c'est l'occasion de mettre à
l'honneur des sports nouveaux de les
faire connaître de les faire monter en
puissance la saison seulement la break
danceuse sia Dembélé espère représenter
la France aux Jeux olympiques et se
réjouit de voir sa discipline dans la
compétition
de journée des écoliers ont aussi pu
s'essayer à ces nouvelles disciplines et
peut-être se rêver en futur champion
olympique
et voilà cette découverte de nouvelles
disciplines pour les sénateurs et puis
pour pour évidemment les les
passants pardon du jardin
oui bah c'est bien c'est vrai qu'on
pourrait être un peu bon faut pas être
trop conservateur c'est vrai que je
demande le breakdance est-ce que c'est
une un sport ou un loisir bon
je vais m'y essayer dès maintenant et la
prochaine fois d'ailleurs je viendrai
pour danser sur la table donc
ça donne du plaisir à tout le monde et
que ça donne de l'enthousiasme ça c'est
bien ce genre de choses imagine que ça
va se multiplier dans toute la ville
pendant un an quoi parce que les légions
vont commencer à vivre maintenant avec
la découverte effectivement de ces
nouvelles disciplines Alex on va parler
d'autres sujets avec vous regardez ce
qu'elle a une de la presse régionale
[Musique]
et Alex elle a une de la Provence
l'entrée au panthéon des Manouchian
couple de résistants effectivement on a
appris hier une nouvelle entrée au
Panthéon ce sera à l'an prochain celle
de Mina camisak Manouchian figure de la
Résistance rescapée du génocide arménien
à Patrick communiste il a été fusillé en
1944 par l'armée allemande sur le Mont
Valérien sa femme Mélinée résistante
comme lui et qui lui a survécu 45 ans
entrera également dans ce temple de la
République interrogé par le journal La
Provence le cinéaste Robert guediglian
qui a réalisé un film sur Missak
Manouchian en 2009 L'armée du crime
salut cette panthéonisation je le cite
réaffirmé que des étrangers ont
participé à la résistance et ils ont
laissé leur vie va à l'encontre de tous
les propos diffamatoires diffamatoires
que l'on entend aujourd'hui sur
l'immigration leur action est un
formidable vaccin d'antirassismes le
salon de l'aéronautique couvre
aujourd'hui au Bourget alex
va devoir le secteur de l'aviation va
devoir faire face aux défis climatique
avec un objectif
développer une flotte aérienne sans
carbone mais actuellement le principal
problème des constructeurs d'avion et
bien c'est de répondre à la demande des
compagnies aériennes qui est en plein
boom même si le secteur n'a pas repris
le rythme d'avant covid les commandes
sont en forte hausse plus de 7000 avions
sont déjà notés dans le carnet de
commandes du groupe Airbus et cela
relance l'emploi par exemple en
Loire-Atlantique et bien Airbus va
recruter 800 CDI à temps plein cette
année pour faire face et bien au boom du
secteur elle a une du journal l'union
des premières bouteilles de vin blanc
dans les hauts de France effectivement
l'avenir du vin est peut-être dans les
Hauts-de-France puisque 40000 premières
bouteilles de vin blanc ont été
commercialisés vont être commercialisés
dans les hauts de France à partir du
mois de juin de ce mois-ci le projet est
né en 2019 autour du groupe terno VO et
de 11 exploitants un agricoles qui ont
planté les vignes notamment dans le
département de la Somme elle est 20
assemblées sont à base du cépage
Chardonnay et objectif à long terme de
la production 450 000 bouteilles par an
et puis on finit Oriane parlait Une de
La Dépêche du Midi consacrée au triom
des joueurs de rugby du Stade Toulousain
sacré champion de France samedi après
une victoire dans les dernières minutes
face à La Rochelle 29 à 26 hier les
joueurs ont brandi leur boucliers de
Brennus sur la place du Capitole à
Toulouse il y avait une communion entre
le public et leurs idoles et puis il
faut dire que les Toulousains sont assez
habitués à ce genre de fête puisque ce
titre était le 22e 22e titre de champion
de France pour le stade tous les ans
Nathalie on
va regarder des nombreuses une des
journaux du groupe ABBA celle du
Républicain Lorrain où sont passés les
saisonniers oui c'est un dossier qui est
dans tous les jeux journaux du groupe
Evra aujourd'hui effectivement c'est un
vrai souci mais pour tous les secteurs
du tourisme qui manquent de bras donc ça
veut dire que il peut y avoir des barres
des restaurants qui ferment un petit peu
plus tôt enfin c'est un vrai vrai souci
donc c'est à dire aujourd'hui dans nos
journées et elle a Une du Figaro et Yves
le remaniement qui vire aux cassettes
pour Emmanuel Macron oui
on revient aussi nous au Figaro sur la
stratégie de LR et les relations entre
le la majorité le président de la
République et LRZ dans le Figaro merci
beaucoup
[Musique]
si vous voulez voir revoir cette
émission c'est sur public sénat.fr
prochain rendez-vous à 18h sens publique
Thomas Hugh et puis à 19h audition
publique avec Louise effectivement
le fondateur et organisateur des
journées d'Aix-en-Provence et ce sera à
suivre
à partir de journée
[Musique]